[Music]
today I'd like to talk about
democratizing our using the plumber
package and so to get started what I
want to do is kind of go through and
provide an introduction to plumber if
you are perhaps unfamiliar with the
package or haven't been exposed to it
before and then highlight some new
features that we have that allow us to
integrate more tightly with open API and
things of that nature and then finally
and walk through a use case a may be
typical example use case of what plumber
could be used for and then and then walk
through a demonstration of what that
might look like so if you're unfamiliar
plumber is an art package that allows
you to create API endpoints around
common art functions so you can define
any sort of art function that you're
interested in and then with a few simple
commands you can turn that our function
into an endpoint that can then be
interacted with via any sort of API call
this looks like an example plumber
script would look something like this
and again if you if you haven't been
exposed to plumber before there may be
some pieces in here that aren't quite
recognisable but for the most part if we
kind of abstract away the specific
plumber parts for just a moment this
this starts to look like just a typical
our script right at the top here I load
the plumber package I load in some saved
data object that I have and I apologize
if this is a little small on the back
and this this is all available on github
and I'll make sure you have the link to
to review this later but then I load
some some save data object and then
finally I define a function that
interacts with that object will dive
into this function perhaps a little bit
later I'm in our demonstration but in
essence this looks and feels like our
code because it is to look at the
plumber specific pieces as we walk
through this plumber uses specialized
annotations and these are just special
comments written in the regular comment
syntax and are with the hash symbol and
then that's followed by a little
asterisk and this allows us to annotate
our document or our source script in a
way that plumber can then understand and
interpret our just standard our code and
turn it into these API so here this
initial these a few initial comments
here provide an API name and description
from a API so I'm calling this the the
empty cars model API and it provide a
little description about what's going to
happen the next step that I have is I
have this filter that's the
fine and a filter is used when I had I
have some sort of logic that I want to
take place on an incoming request before
it's served to an end point and so this
is where I could do something like if I
want to provide some sort of
authentication on incoming requests I
could use a filter to do that here this
example filter simply takes some
information from the incoming request
such as where this is coming from the
user ID associated with it a timestamp
and prints that out so that I have a
nice log available to me of who's
interacting with my API as well as the
frequency that this API is being
interacted with so anytime a request is
made this information would be printed
out and I could capture that finally we
have the function that I started with
when we when we demonstrated this our
code and I just have a few different
things that I have that I've annotated
on this function I've given it a name
and a little description and then I've
defined the end point that this function
should respond to so again I apologize
if it's a little small
but I've defined that this function will
respond or will be called when the
predict endpoint is is accessed with a
post request to go a little bit further
once I have all these annotations in
place and I actually run this API this
thing on the right hand side gets
generated for me and as Ann argues err
when I was first exposed to plumber this
was like a mind-blowing moment because
I'm not a I'm not I wasn't overly
familiar with api's they seem kind of
scary to me as an our user for a little
while I was like this this thing that
everybody knows about I don't know what
it is right but I started using plumber
and as soon as I ran the API all of a
soon as I ran my API all of a sudden
free of charge I have this nice little
interface that would pop up and not only
show me what my API looks like but it
allows me to touch and feel the API to
make sure that it's operating as I would
expect if we look at a comparison
between the code that we've written and
this file and user interface that's been
generated we can start to see how these
two things are connected here I see that
my title has been copied from my my
source code into this into this user
interface I can see that the description
matches the description that I defined
in my our script and finally I have this
endpoint that's been defined this
predict endpoint that shows that it's
going to respond to post requests and it
shows the description that I provided in
Morse in my source code this sort of
magical experience as made
possible to the use of open API now what
open API is it was formerly referred to
as swagger this is a specification so
it's a set of guidelines that defines a
way that you can go through and I didn't
it essentially described an entire API
the endpoints the attributes of those
endpoints everything from kind of the
top to bottom of your API can be
described using this particular
specification there's a few different
ways this can happen you can write like
a gamma file which is the example that I
have put up on the screen you could also
create a JSON file that is then ingested
and interpreted by open API to provide
things like the user interface we were
just looking at plummer interacts with
open api in a couple of different ways
we've already been exposed to one and
that is through these specialized
comments where we have the hash symbol
followed by an asterisk and then
typically some sort of decorator like an
@ symbol and what happens is plumber
will parse our parse the file identify
these special comments and then insert
those into a named list that is finally
processed into a JSON file that open API
will read and provide us with the user
interface now this this functionality
has been in plumbers since essentially
day one and one of the nice advantages
here is that my annotations my
documentation my description is all
closely connected to my code there right
next to one another however there are
some limitations here and that is the
entire suite of options that are
available through open I open API is
very broad right and so it's not
feasible to consider creating a
specialized plumber annotation that
provides access to every single feature
available in using the open API
specification and I'm happy to announce
that given some recent efforts that have
that have happened with the plumber
package we now have the opportunity to
update and adjust the full open API
specification at runtime of the plumber
API what this looks like is over here on
the right hand side I have an entry
point file that plumber will read and in
this entry point file I define at
runtime a swagger function that
essentially will take in a few different
arguments and all it needs to return is
a named list that can be appropriately
parsed into JSON that open API can
interpret so I can update anything that
I've that I've written or I can add
additional attributes to my API in fact
if I wanted to I could overwrite
everything the plumber is already
automatically done and just create my
own specify
I can file from API to be ingested and
then rendered for the end-user given
this introduction let's consider an
example use case as a data scientist I'm
often handed a piece of data and asked
to provide some insight and I go through
this process that's described in our for
data science I ingest the data I do some
cleaning of my data and then finally I
go through this iterative process of
trying to understand the story or
understand the insight that should be
delivered from my data being a data
scientist that means I'm often creating
models and so I'm gonna dig deep into my
bag of tricks and let's let's do
something cutting-edge let's make a
linear model out of this data right
we've gone through we've cleaned this up
and we've created this model the next
step now is to present the results and
as an AR user there's a variety of
different ways that I can do this I can
create a PowerPoint presentation I can
create an hour markdown document maybe
it's an email that I send my tool of
choice when I'm faced with this
opportunity to communicate is to build a
shiny application and this allows me to
build some sort of interactive web you
whether web user interface that users
can then access to touch and play with
the the model that I've developed right
now I can publish this application to
something like our studio connect and
then I can have my end-users come into
the picture and they're able to come in
and interact with my model and get the
insight that they need and now I'm in
this happy place where I have a shiny
application that's sitting on top of all
the work that I just did and it's
servicing all these end users whether
these are fellow analysts business users
managers within my department whatever
the case is they're able to come in and
in a very intuitive way they can
interact with my application they can
interact with my model via this web
application that I provided now I've
been in this position before and this is
a great feeling to have right I've done
all this hard work and now people are
using it and it's getting recognition
and I'm helping people's ideally I'm I'm
helping make people's lives better in
some way as this model starts to gain
traction and as this application starts
to gain traction something always
happens at least in my experience um
thing always happens and that is another
set of users slowly start to appear and
these users are a little bit different
than the traditional user base because
they don't want a web application they
want programmatic access to whatever
I've done right they want to be able to
access the underlying model and
typically it's at this point in the
process where I start to scratch my head
and say well we've had a good run right
because I know this is what's coming I'm
going to go to one of these engineers
and I'm going to get something like this
in return now this is not because our is
bad and go is good or vice-versa right
this is because these are different
languages designed for different
purposes and I've been in many
conversations with software engineers
where they're trying so hard to
understand my our code and I'm trying so
hard to explain it but that handoff
always has some amount of friction
associated with it and up until recently
that in my mind has just been kind of
this necessary evil right at some point
my little baby art project has to grow
up and into the real world of software
engineering I proposed today that
there's actually a better solution and
that solution is to use Plummer as the
intermediary here instead of going
directly to building a shiny application
I could instead expose my model or
whatever it is that I've worked on as a
plumber API and now I've given myself
the flexibility to not only service end
users who want programmatic access to
the work that I've done I can still
continue to service my regular users
right by using a shiny application to
access this API so that my traditional
user base that are used to a web
interface can continue to use the work
that I've done and at this point now
everybody's happy
so what does this look like let's take a
look a short demo into our studio and so
here we've got the the our Studio IDE
this is a plumber file that I have
opened this is the one that we've been
kind of looking at and so I just want to
walk through a few different things that
are happening here and then we'll run
this and take a look at what what
happens under the hood so I load the
plumber package and then as I mentioned
before I have this model that I've saved
now this is a very simplistic example
but the idea here is this could be a
broad range of things right there was a
great talk given earlier about serving
Cara's and and tensorflow models using
plumber right so it's really limitless
in the scope of what you can do here so
I've loaded this model in again I have
this filter that logs some information
about my incoming requests and then
finally I have this endpoint that that
listens on this predict location in
response to incoming post requests and
what this function does if we look
through this it's actually fairly
straightforward it
anticipates that the incoming request
contains a post body object and it
anticipates that that post body object
is JSON and so it will try to parse that
JSON into a native our data frame if it
can't it returns an error to the user
otherwise it takes this new our data
frame and sends it to my model to
generate new predictions now one of the
nice things about Plummer is that by
default any response that's generated
within my within my endpoint function is
automatically serialized into JSON which
is a language that most other computer
programming languages or toolkits would
be able to naturally ingest and
understand all right so once this
prediction is made down here with this
predict call the resulting predicted
values will be returned as a JSON array
to whatever the to whichever client made
this request now typically when I've
done something like this and I've built
several different API zin in this
fashion this is where Plummer previously
has kind of been stretched to its limits
in terms of what it can do from a
documentation in an interactivity
perspective and that is because there's
no way for me with these annotations to
specify details about the request body
itself and so when I would run this I
would get the nice interface and I would
be able to click on my predict endpoint
but I would have no way to really
interact with it I would need some other
tool chain right I could use curl from
the command line I could use postman or
some other API client but I needed some
other tool to verify that things were
working however like I mentioned earlier
with the newest updates and plumber I
can now specify anything that I want
about the API specification at runtime
of my plumber API so here I have this
this I'm loading the plumber file and
then I'm using this run method I've
passed a function into swagger and here
I'm just here on defining what the
request body to this predict endpoint
should look like and when I run this
file and then I want to point out for
just a moment that in the newest version
of the our studio IDE
there's some nice tooling built around
plumber so I can automatically run the
API from from within the IDE with this
running API button and when I click on
this let me expand over here I now have
this nice user interface just like I've
come to expect but the nice thing is is
I scroll down here I can see my post
endpoint if I open this up notice it
says no parameters which is fine I
didn't define any parameters but this
traditionally where it stopped right and
I wanted some mechanism to test this out
now however I see this request body and
it shows me not only an example of what
this should look like it shows me what
the schema is and then it gives me the
opportunity to say well okay this is
what it looks like let me try this out
and here's some values that are that are
pre-populated by by default but I could
come over and I already have this pulled
up so I could come over and grab some
JSON data this is just a selection of
the empty cars data in R and I can come
over here and edit this paste it in
execute go and so a couple of things
happen now we see the curl command that
was generated here we see the URL that I
made this request to so this is just
running locally right now and I've made
a request to this predict endpoint and
then if I go down here I see the
response body so this is the predicted
value the predicted miles-per-gallon
value of this JSON data that I just
passed in the Plumber and notice that I
never left our studio I built this API I
tested this API I verified that
everything was working all from within
our studio now some of you at this point
may be thinking okay that's great
right this is all well and good James
but is the handoff really this easy
right is it really as easy as you made
it seem and I've had that question
myself and so I was actually on a phone
call
this past weekend with a with a close
college friend of mine and I was going
through my talk and kind of telling him
about what I was gonna be demonstrating
and everything like that and he and he
was following along he's a mobile app
developer and at the end of the talk he
said well send me you know send me some
information or send me the the github
repo to your API and now this is an API
that I've published to our studio
konnekt it's it's open and it's
available and so I sent him the repo no
I really didn't think anything of it and
a couple of days later I got this in a
text message now my friend that knows
how to spell our and that's the end
right he has no working knowledge of our
he's never interacted with our in any
sort of context yet here he's built an
entire mobile app using Swift that's
interacting with our built by somebody
who doesn't know our this is
plumber enables us to do right we can
now go straight from I have this idea in
concept to I have this idea that anyone
else can interact with whether it's a
shiny application or it's some it's a
mobile application it's some sort of
Java process whatever the case is I have
now opened up the work that I'm doing to
a much broader audience if you'd like to
take a look at some of the recent
changes that have been made they haven't
quite made it to cran yet but you can
download the the recent changes from
github so you could do that in this
manner and then there are some
additional resources that are available
in the Plumber documentation as well as
if you're curious about open api and
what that specification entails and then
the the github repository for this talk
and the materials that i've used are
here as well thank you very much
[Applause]
so we have some time for questions right
here thank you is there anything on the
roadmap for testing API so right now
what we're doing is we're opening the
API in one-hour session and then running
a script with with our test calls to the
endpoints that we've written in other
will there be a certain more elegant way
of doing that either in in the IDE or
elsewhere
yeah and I've thought about that I don't
there's nothing on the roadmap right now
primarily because since we've opened
this up as canvas you know for like a
better a better term terminology a REST
API endpoint there's lots of tooling
that exists around testing those types
of those types of endpoints and so we
trust that users could could leverage
some of the existing tooling at this
point I don't necessarily see a need for
us to recreate something but it's it's
worth maybe continuing to think about
for like validation of requests
something that's you can kind of say
here all the required parameters without
like specifying inside the method
checking for things one by one yeah so
that that's where filters come in and
that kind of goes back to this broader
idea of well you know sometimes I field
questions about is there integrated
security are there ways to verify things
about the incoming requests right now
there's not any sort of magic
incantation that says hey you know
verify this request or something like
that that's kind of up to me as the API
developer or the our developer to say
you know maybe I defined some filters
that check for certain attributes maybe
you know it might be something like a
security token or it might be something
like I'm checking a timestamp to make
sure that people aren't making requests
beyond operating hours there's that
right I so you have the flexibility to
really define any criteria that you want
but we don't provide anything
out-of-the-box that provides
verification or anything like that
what's that okay
do you guys have any mom like hubs of
like lots of examples of plumber api's
because I find it kind of hard sometimes
to find examples and try to mimic them
yeah we are working on building out some
resources so the plumber documentation
and plumber examples are something that
we're working on building out and and
we'll make sure that those are widely
announced and publicized when they begin
they become available and ETA sometime
soon but we're definitely that's
something that I'm trying to work on as
well as is building out some of these
examples and everything go to questions
really quickly first can you specify a
dependency say a preparatory data set
yes don't exposed to the outside
and the second part is where this
background process is running and do you
have a control over it yeah great
question so I'm kind of two parts there
the first part is can i specify
something external in the example that
we just looked at I actually had a
serialized art object that I loaded from
disk right so I loaded this model that I
previously trained from disk and then it
was available to any process referenced
within that within that API so I could
do that with a flat file or something
like that and then one of the nice
advantages of publishing to something
like our studio konnekt is those
dependencies get identified and I can
automatically send those files with my
API source code and then in terms of
where this where this the underlying
process is running in the example we
just looked at this was just running
locally as soon as I hit run API and
actually just spun up a small web server
on my machine just to surface this API
when I publish it I there's a variety of
ways you can deploy this thing my
recommendation is rstudio connect
because you have the click button
deployment but the the Plumber
documentation runs through a variety of
deployment options
I have a deployment related question so
I saw that RS Connect deploys today to
like the pro server but not to like
anything else like digitalocean is there
is that in the roadmap for you guys to
include to make it easier to deploy to
anything beyond just the pro server so
the as it stands right now the
publishing from within di within the IDE
right so so just as a kind of a
reference I meant to showcase this um
from within the IDE we mentioned that I
have this I have access to run API up
here I also have access to this publish
button where I could publish this to our
studio konnekt that's that's where that
interaction ends right but but there's
again in the documentation for plumber
there's some guidelines around if you
wanted to publish to maybe digital ocean
for example there's some guidelines
around how you might do that but I don't
anticipate integration of that type of
workflow into the IDE
just a quick question with the new
improvements you showed to different
files you were working on with the open
API think is that the same one coded
differently with the new improvements
with open API or are those two two files
I mean is it the same thing I guess yeah
so there's there's two different files
that are at play here one is the Plumber
file and this defines all of the our
logic plummer also has this concept of
an entry point file which if plummer if
when I run an API that it's the Plumber
API it will look for an entry point our
file within that same folder within that
same directory and if it finds it it
will use that to find additional details
about the API so here I could
programmatically alter my API I could
add additional routers but what I'm
doing in this case is I'm just simply
updating the specification file with
this named list that will then get
parsed into JSON and rendered the way
that we saw it awesome well the more
question if you can say a few your a few
words regarding scaling I mean how many
post can candy support can this scale up
yeah that's the classic question right
does our scale and the answer is yes
absolutely and it really depends on the
way in which you the way in which you
choose to deploy this if you deploy this
to our studio konnekt you can actually
go in and adjust the number of processes
that are dedicated to the support of
that API so so the notion here and part
of the underlying question I think is
well I know there are single threaded if
I'm running R on the back end of my API
I anticipate that there may be
challenges for skating with scalability
our studio konnekt provides a solution
to that by allowing you to spin up
concurrent art processes that support
your API so essentially you add this
notion of multi-threaded no stew to your
our process and then there's again
depending on the way in which you choose
to deploy this you could deploy this in
in an environment where it you know
maybe at auto scales and some sort of a
docker cluster or something like that so
it's really up to you in terms of how do
you want to deploy this thing but it
certainly is able to to scale and meet a
high load of demand I know that in the
talk I was in earlier where they were
discussing
using this at t-mobile they mentioned
having you know serving a very very
large customer base and in their mobile
app interfaces using plumber and
accessing our api's that way and they've
had no issues with it so thank you all
again very much
you
[Music]